[Music]
hello everyone welcome to this talk
about best practices that we have learnt
in google production security and how we
can apply them with sto so the focus for
today's sorry one of the focus for today
we will will talk about how the
production landscape is changing right
what is its impact on network security
and why Google's approach is actually
increasingly relevant and now more
approachable than ever for the
enterprise and sto is a means to an end
of achieving a security purpose right
the key thing is to implement a set of
key security principles that we have
learned over the years to protect
microservices infrastructures within
Google's production and that's what we
will talk about and I am Samrat ray I'm
a product manager on Google cloud
security and privacy organization and my
focus is on service security and insider
threat with me is Julian birth he is the
network security lead for Google's
production and I think this session is
special in the sense that you get to
hear from the people who actually build
the stuff which is Julian right versus
the people who generally talk about it
so so with that with further without
further delays I'll hand it over to
Julian to start explaining how he sees
the threat model evolve or with the
changing production needs and and then
talk about how Google production the
principles of Google production security
that have informed our posture for over
the last decade or so all right thank
you very much Samrat
and hi everyone so production
infrastructure is changing right and
that has a big impact on security
so we are serving a number of trends
from our customers and our partners and
they are like three major trends that I
want to talk about the first trend is
the use of orchestration frameworks and
containers and the the most popular of
these orchestration frameworks is
kubernetes today the second trend is the
use of hybrid and multi-cloud meaning
that one workload may be in one
environment on premise and can move to
another environment on a cloud provider
and the third trend is the adoption of
micro services so let's let's start with
containers and an hybrid and I will I
will have a big claim here is that IP
base network security is suboptimal so
your IP tables can only go so far and
why is that that's because when you
think about it on accusation framework
is going to schedule containers on a
pool of hosts right and the
orchestration framework can kill the
workload on a hosts
reschedule that another the hosts and as
a consequence the IP and the hosts IP in
particular doesn't have a lot of
relevance anymore
right these containers also these
workloads they are ephemeral then can be
start and stop very quickly now for
hybrid as I said you will have a
workload that starts on an environment
on premise and then that moves to
another environment which is cloud and
when that occurs you don't want to have
to reprogram all you network policies
because the subnet is not the same right
and so what that means is that we need
policies and access logs like policies
on access logs they need to have a
stable identifier for the workload the
other trend is micro services and when
you think about you all monolith all
monolith monolithic application where
everything was integrating in one big
binary that-that-that-that Molly's got
exploded into a constellation of
microservices and as a consequence calls
function call that used to be local are
now completely distributed over the
network and what that means in terms of
network security is that your network is
much more privileged now if you don't do
anything about it
meaning that somebody who has a
privileged stance on the network is able
to do be able to do much more damage
than before so so we need a solution for
that the other point that I want to make
around micro-services is that they
expose a lot of different methods and
let's take an example of a key
distribution service for example this
key distribution service is going to
expose some methods that have very
different security properties one method
call can be completely innocuous such as
a health check you want to check whether
the service is dead or alive and you
will have another call that is going to
be rotating the master key and this one
needs to be really heavy protected and
again what this means is that the
policies need to be able to reason about
these different methods and the
different levels of privilege so that
means the policies have to go way beyond
layer 3 on layer 4 they have to operate
at layer 7 so the good news here to some
extent is that adoption of containerized
workloads and micro services that's what
Google has been doing for the last 10
years we've been doing that over a
decade and we have in production
millions of of microservices endpoints
and so we're informing our network
security posture by a set of principles
and I'm going to talk about these
principles now so I'm going to start
this part of the talk by a quote from
News Provost Neal's used to be our
security horizontal lead and he gave a
talk on production security in this very
forum a couple of years ago and at the
time he said at Google we are not
pursuing a hard shell parameter model
instead we really focused on prefaces
defense-in-depth there's another term
that you may have heard about pervasive
defense-in-depth and it's zero trust
security so personally I'm not a big fan
of zero trust security because at the
end of the day you have to trust
something or a set of things right you
if you go with an identity based system
you will have to trust your identity
provider your identity if you're on
system you will have to trust your
network for availability in any case so
I prefer the term difference in depth
which i think is more correct and you
can see difference in depth along a set
of dimensions and a first dimension
maybe how to build your stack on a
production machine from a hardware tool
of trusts to a bootloader to an
operating system to containers and
applications and how do do you make sure
that at each layer what you're running
is what you think is running
that's not malicious code and that's one
type
what one dimension of difference in
depth the other type of difference in
depth that that we can think about is
along the network path and how you can
have two layers of security one that is
at the edge of the perimeter well at the
edge of the protection network and the
other that is inside within the
production network and since we don't
have that much time today we're going to
focus on the second one the network path
so the first principle that we have is
that so we need two layers so the first
layer is that you have to protect your
protection network at the edge right and
proxies are the thing that provides this
isolation you can see on this diagram
here you have our customers the blue and
the yellow person has going through the
Google front end in order to invoke a
service at Google this Google front end
is going to do a bunch of security
checks and you can see that if an
attacker tries to attack us here with
for example a denial of service attack
we can detect this attack and we can
react appropriately through aggressive
like rate limiting for example now for
workloads that are within the network we
ensure that these workloads cannot
arbitrarily egress out to the internet
because that would be an obvious vector
for exfiltration of data so we have
perimeter security here as well and even
with within our corporate network we
make sure that in order to access the
production network we go through an
administrative proxy and you may have
heard of beyond Corp which is something
that we're very keen on but there are
sometimes some misconception about what
beyond Corp is about so beyond Corp is
about the fact that being on the
corporate network
per se doesn't just give you access to
the production network there are a bunch
of other signals that you need to take
into account in order for you to have
access to some privileged resources
within the production network and these
the things are for example what is the
device from which you're operating this
request to the production network is it
to trusty device is it an ultra C device
who is the person who is authenticated
on this device is it a Google employee
is it something else right and the admin
proxy is the one that will based on all
the signal and the type of resource that
you want to access in the production
network to make the decision as to
whether you can or cannot access the
resource in question the thing that I
want to tell you here is that you you
don't stop there right you don't stop at
the parameter within the production
network you have to protect your clothes
for all the reasons that we talked about
before with respect to micro services
for example so how do we do that the
first thing that we do is that we use
federal shows backed identities for all
the entities on the network and the
entities are the administrators the
machines and the workloads and let me
talk to you about a LTS because alt s is
a application layer Transport Security
is also known as Louis and that is the
system that we use to do this type of
thing so
LT s does two main things the first
thing that it does is that it provisions
rotates and revokes all the credentials
for all these different entities but the
first thing that it does but alts is
also at
for security protocol meaning that it's
very extremely similar to mutual TLS and
its certificate based and private key
based so now let's see how Alice who is
a site reliability engineer can schedule
a workload which is dual or front-end on
a production machine so the first thing
that Alice does is that Alice makes a
request to the wall master which is our
scheduler our men scheduler for
workloads and he gives the description
of the doodle fronting workload and she
also says I want this workload to run as
the doodle from 10 identity and she does
that over on alts which we authenticated
channel once the ball master receives
these requests the ball master is going
to do two types of checks the first
check is going to be those alleys have
the rights to start a workload as the
doodle frontal identity the first thing
right
it does can she act as this identity and
the second check that is going to be
done is that oh but this workloads comes
with a configuration about the binaries
that are going to be running and do we
have some information about the
provenance of this binary and that's
called binary authorization 1 these two
checks are cleared the ball master will
then choose a production machine a
worker machine on yellow here and we'll
threw on alts channel again that is
materials authenticated and encrypted
send the configuration to the pro
machine of dual front end along with the
credentials for the role for the end and
now dual front end can authenticate to
any of the other entities that we
described before
for example dude on front end is going
to authenticate to
another another workload which is going
to be doodled back-end through again on
alts mutually authenticated channel and
from the doodled back-end standpoint
dual front end is going to appear as the
client authenticated entity another
principle that we have is to use channel
bound credentials for authenticated
services within the production network
so what is a channel you can see the
channel as a TLS session between a
client and a server and by channel bound
what I mean is that the proof of
authentication is only relevant within
the context of this channel so
authentication credentials can be of two
forms one can be certificate and private
keys and the other can be bearer tokens
and you can see on the web that bearer
tokens are pretty popular but we've been
strongly that they're the wrong choice
for authenticating within you
infrastructure why is that is that
basically bearer token by their very
nature can be replayed and that is a big
issue here because you have doodled
fronting on one one end we need to talk
to do roll back end on the other end but
that's unique that's not the only
channel of communication that exists
dual front end is going to talk to a
bunch of different other services such
as the load reporting service or the
lock service or the name resolution
service and when that happens you don't
want the lord reporting service or any
of these services to be able to replay
the bearer token of doodled front end to
doodle backend in other terms to
impersonate doodle front end to the -
sorry dude in fact solidoodle front end
to the back end and what that means is
that
we really want general bank credentials
and so again for in your production we
use alt s which is certificate and
private key based and that doesn't
suffer from this big drawback of where
tokens another principle is that you
have to be able to grant access based on
multiple identities and that's not
something that you can do with like
again policies just add the layer 3 on
layer for each service each workload
exposes methods and sometimes user data
and all this access might be explicitly
authorized by policies now let's talk
about the different identities that we
have here on the network on the on the
request path you first have the workload
identities or service identity or
channel identities or P identities all
these things are the same the same thing
and these are ingress front and back and
health service these are the identity
that I talked about previously but at
the beginning of the request you also
have another identity which is the
original requester identity and that can
be for example Bob checking his gmail on
his phone and he's very important for
this original requester identity to be
forwarded along the chain from ingress
to the database because at the end of
the chain it's Bob's data that we want
to retrieve from the database and let's
see how this can work hand in hand with
the peer identities along the chain each
workload can decide which peer
identities are allowed to present such
original requester identities and here
for example from the database point of
view the database can say
it's perfectly legitimate for the
backend to present me with our original
requester identity but a half service
which is just there to make sure that
I'm alive this one is certainly not
privileged to present me with an
end-user identity the fifth principle
which is going to be the last year and
that's probably the most important one
is that your platform must implement
security by default and if you see this
diagram here you have what is provided
by the platform which is at the bottom
and the application logic which is at
the top the platform supplies service a
and service B with credentials with an
identity automatically without the
application having to think about it
without the application they'd rather
have it to think about that you know
there's some magic key distribution
going on here
it just happens when a wants to call the
get info method on B again just by
virtue of using the RPC framework
automatically a channel is created a
mutually authenticated channel that will
now say that the caller is a service and
the collie is B service and the service
owners are going to to be able to
configure some authorization checks here
for example service we can say identity
a service can access B dot get info and
this is the since this is the case here
the call is going to be able to go
through but again all this happens at
the platform level without the
involvement of of the application logic
and that's really important now there
maybe some types of authorization that
really need some context from the
request itself and such applications are
typically heavily melt multi-tenant so
if you want an example you can think of
a a file or directory service right
depending on the path that is in the
request you will want to apply one type
of authorization versus another type of
authorization depending on the path and
but even for these types of applications
even authorization checks fine-grained
access we want to provide framework for
that and internally Google I am is a
good way a good framework for achieving
this so let's recap here the five
principles that we talked about so the
first one is protect your network at the
edge second one is to use credentials
backed identities for all the entities
on the network the third one is to use
channel bound credentials for
authenticating services for to grant
access based on multiple identities if
this is applicable you don't always have
multiple identities but if you do you
grant access based on that and the fifth
one and the most important one again is
that the prima the platform implements
security by default and I cannot stress
that enough if there's one thing that I
want you to take away from this talk is
that is the role of the platform for
security like don't let each team of you
in your organization reinvent the wheel
reinvent its own framework settle on one
thing and make it better over time
so if Co security has been informed by
all these principles and now some rot
will tell you how these principles are
being implemented in this view Thank You
Julian so Julian outplayed some very
important principles
about how we at Google protect our
production environment against some
fairly sophisticated attacks right and
increasingly if we find as enterprises
get more digitized and move to cloud
platforms enterprises are exposed to
similar sort of threats that Google has
been exposed to over the years and we
feel that it's increasingly relevant
that enterprises adopt such principles
to protect their own production
environment however one of the big
challenges here is I'm sure all of you
realized what yulian presented was
technically complex right it's
non-trivial to do this in any shape or
form in an enterprise environment right
and one of the things you immediately
that strikes you and when it when when
Julian presents something like this was
that how does this apply to my
production environment it doesn't look
anything like Google's production
environment at all right the problem is
not hundreds of millions of endpoints
it's not scale the problem is
heterogeneity right
I have different workloads from
different generations using different
protocols using different languages all
sitting within my data center there is
no uniform deployment model right there
across different kinds of runtimes there
is no standard application frameworks
like the kind Julian described right
because it's been acquired over time
across various third-party software in
many cases so this new security approach
which was described elegantly it's
actually very technically complex to
roll out in my environment right and
lastly even if I do a time to roll it
out how do I ensure the success of this
how do I measure this how do I get a
visibility in such a complex environment
as how to achieve this and as a product
manager these are the kind of problems
that we that we landed up thinking about
as to like how do we make what is really
necessary from a security perspective
much more accessible to the enterprise
customer and with that is how we started
thinking about this problem we didn't
start thinking about saying we want to
build security features for sto actually
we weren't even thinking about history
when we started off with this problem we
wanted to make these security principles
and this posture more approachable right
and we started thinking about how we can
do that and it is over time and looking
at this problem in a incremental manner
that we realized that having something
like sto is very important
way to enable enterprises to be able to
adopt these principles so let's talk
about the primitives that build up to
form sto and make this possible
right the first thing that you need to
do given your heterogeneous
infrastructure and and the fact that you
have all kinds of protocols and
languages is the ability to virtualize
this application or network endpoint
right and envoy is a sidecar but
something that you know our senior
technical leads did a long evaluation
across a bunch of models and they came
up and said this is the most optimal way
of achieving this goal right and so that
gives us this abstraction in addition to
so a key thing about that abstraction is
now you can start being a transparent to
your application code because this now
becomes your policy enforcement point
right and as well as policy monitoring
and network monitoring point right so
now you certainly have something that is
the equivalent of a NIC card but at the
application level right that gives you
all these properties right another key
feature which we did invest in an envoy
was to make sure that the TCP support
was more robust because this is one of
the key things that differentiates a
homogeneous infrastructure that's all
restful to something that there's more
enterprise like right and so with this
in place you can now have uniform policy
enforcement and you can have uniform
access metrics and logs the second
question you might ask is I get the
value of on four I get the value of
having a proxy but why do I need a
service mesh what is the service mesh I
know I have a mess in my production
environment do I really need a mesh on
top of that so it's yeah the name mesh
is a bit of a marketing ploy right what
it really is is a way to virtualize your
network at the application levels to
some extent right and in order to do
that you actually need just like with
any other networking software or you
need a control plane right and you need
a control plane that can scale to
thousands of services and just like any
other networking system you need to have
a central policy control or central
policy visibility and you need to wait
to have a notion of being able to reason
about who is talking to whom right and
you're able to do that at the l3 level
with your tools and you must be able to
do that at this level right and how do
we achieve that the proxies by
themselves are not enough
right and sto really solves for those
problems right so we chose this to you
not because it's a cool thing but
because it actually solves a real
problem from a security perspective so
going forward is to does more than just
security obviously for those who have
familiar with it it does traffic
management like load balancing as well
as things like ability to route with
layer 7 semantics of course it does
security and we'll deep dive into that
today a little bit more and it does
telemetry which allows you to get
various kinds of signals around
performance and error rates to make sure
that your services are more reliable and
and performant so we go back and look at
those five principles and how you can
apply them using the technologies that
we provide on Google cloud and through
Sto
so the first is about protecting your
VPC in the context of cloud your
production environment can be
represented as your V PC right and how
do you protect that at the edge the
there are two main things to achieve
here there are two things to do here one
is to protect your public facing
endpoints right and protect them against
internet-based threats so we provide a
couple of technologies there which are
very powerful one is cloud armor you
will induct about DDoS protection cloud
armor allows you to it's sort of a
sophisticated you ask which also has
DDoS protection baked in right so this
is a critical piece of your front-end
strategy the second is Julian talked a
bit about how we have an admin proxy to
allow beyond cop like principles in
order to grant access for our employees
to gain access to production systems we
have built a corresponding thing called
identity our proxy right which allows
you such four it's a good way to allow
humans and to secure human-based access
to the production environment you having
protected the front end you think of the
parameter actually the parameter is not
just what's facing the Internet in many
cases your parameter may be a
departmental boundary that you wish to
drop within your network sometimes or in
kubernetes landscape we call those
clusters or namespaces right in your
other environments you might call it a
network segment you need to protect that
against other parts of your network that
don't don't have the same level of
sensitivity security sensitivity
this internal segmentation is also
needed and sto ingress is a solution for
that because it's it can act both as a
layer for as well as a layer seven sort
of a proxy in order to segment two
different pieces of your infrastructure
and then once you have this front-end
protected you need to now seal out the
parameter right and that means defending
against exfiltration vectors and control
so one of the things we provide is
firewall policies like these are layer 3
policies to understand like the out to
be able to control outbound
communication from within your network
and now with what is just G a is VPC
service controls which is a way to
extend this notion of a secure perimeter
to multi-tenant cloud services like GCS
and bigquery so that you can implement a
similar parameter strategy for those as
well so this is a diagrammatic view of
what I just talked about right so as you
can see here from a corporate network
you can gain access to our identity our
proxy you have cloud armor in front and
these are actually implemented on
Google's clouds load balancer so they
are effectively policy engine both
identity our proxy and cloud armor on
Google cloud load balancer right
additionally you can now implement an
sto ingress that sits right behind it to
provide additional segmentation so let's
take the second principle using
credentials back to identities for all
entities on your network now Julian
talked about having alt s as being the
source of truth to provide and the
certificate manager to provide
identities to everything administrators
hosts and workloads in your enterprise
typically it's very hard to have this
kind of a uniform way of meaning Trust
it's a assigning trust to users in
two-horse it's typically a solved
problem in most production environments
you have been doing this for many years
right what is really unsolved as a
problem is a way to assign identities in
a secure manner to the workloads so this
is what this tier is trying to solve it
tries to complement what you already
have and add to that by providing a
certificate authority for workloads
which is different from necessarily the
roots of trust that you might use to say
identify users which might be an Active
Directory or identify your hosts which
and in this particular example that
could be the kubernetes
which is able to determine the
trustworthiness of a node on which it is
deployed so in this particular example
taking the same example that Julian gave
but now applying it to kubernetes you
have Alice who is on a corporate
workstation trying to deploy a pod to a
kubernetes cluster right in this
particular case
Alice authenticates to the cluster to
the master and perhaps as a particular
namespace admin with deployment
privileges in order to be able to deploy
so therefore we know she has the right
privileges in order to start doodle dot
front-end over here right at this point
once she is authenticated the master can
then deploy the doodle front-end and it
assigns an identity which we call a
service account right so service
accounts are now becoming a common
parlance it's used in Google cloud
platform AWS and kubernetes they
basically represent an identity that is
typically associated with a workload so
at this point once it's deployed if this
workload were to be part of an sto
enabled environment then there's a node
manager which is running on that
particular node that then is able to use
this identity that was just issued by
the master and create a CSR or a
certificate request to the service mesh
certificate authority right and the
service master certificate authority now
takes this identity and encodes it into
a x.509 credential that is then placed
that is provided to doodle front-end for
authentication traditional x.509
certificates authenticated hosts so we
worked with the open-source community to
have a to come up with a way that
everybody agrees on at least within the
open-source community of encoding a
workload identity into an x.509
certificate this is called spiffy and
the and the format that we all agreed
upon was how it would be encoded in
x.509 and it's just supposed to that and
is able to interplay with any other
party that can also support the spiffy
format for certificates
going to the third principal using
channel bound credentials for
authenticating services Julian touched
upon this lightly I will give a concrete
example to make this real right you can
with sto specify a policy that says all
communications to service B must be
authenticated over mutual TLS right as
in when we talk about channel bound I'll
cover that one more time it must the
identity actually must be a certificate
on the channel right such that that
identity cannot be replayed so in this
particular example assuming the shared
service the logging service was
compromised if you are using if you're
only allowing mutual TLS based
identities for authentication then even
if service a were to presence its
certificate to the logging service the
certificate by itself cannot be replayed
because logging service cannot create a
channel right a TLS channel with the
private keys that correspond to the
certificate right so this is a very key
principle in order for us to mitigate
risk and escalation of privileges
associated with impersonation right so
thus the all peers once you enable this
mutual TLS we can guarantee that all
peers are authenticated using
certificates based specific credentials
that a channel mount however this is
easier said than done for your Bromfield
applications right imagine a world where
you have an application of existing
service you turn on MPLS voila here's
some bunch of phones ringing because a
whole lot of clients which you didn't
know existed weren't enable for MPLS and
they just broke right so it's very hard
to actually do this in practice so one
of the things we did in sto was to
create this mode called permissive mode
and in the permissive mode when you set
it to permissive mode or server can
accept both mutual TLS authenticated
clients as well as regular your existing
clients so does what we would recommend
for your brownfield applications is you
set all your services to this permissive
mode which is now the default mode for
sto and then you ensure that all your
clients are talking MPLS at some point
you are able to determine that all
clients talking to a service are now
mutual TLS enabled and at that point you
can lock this service down by changing
it to a strict mode
we talked about the identity of origin
earlier right and we must be able to
propagate that as a forwardable
credential right so in this particular
in the cloud environment for example you
can use identity aware proxy to
authenticate any human coming from a
portable device you can use certain
principles like which device type etc
when authenticating to identity a web
proxy right so those checks can be done
in order to grant access
now all this context that is part of the
client context can what identity a web
proxy does is it encodes it in a token
which we call RC token it's a form of
JSON web token that has been structured
specifically with great we provide
greater structure and very importantly
it's a short-lived token this reduces
insider risk because if the token is
logged or stolen there is we are
reducing the risk by reducing the time
for which it is valid right where it
stewards value in this process is being
able to authenticate or sorry able to
validate that this token is actually a
valid token by contacting the issuer and
validating the fact that it's a valued
token such that the backend can now
safely use the claims in order to grant
access or influence business behavior
right and thus as you can see it's just
taking care of a lot of the plumbing
that you would normally have to do in
these particular cases going back to the
fourth principle which is granting
access based on multiple identities
right the main reason to do this is to
protect user data so many of you might
be handling data of your customers and
and this is the reason you want to do
this not for any other reason it's not a
traditional network security posture
it's more about user data protecting
that through access control let's take
this example where there is a privileged
in insider for example a support
engineer who can access based upon real
business requirements your user data or
your customer data right but what you
really want the support engineer to do
is to be only be able to access the data
by the case tool because the case tool
implements a lot of your business
policies like for example is there a
valid support ticket against this right
who'da is the support engine you
properly logged in to the system are we
logging all accesses so on and so forth
right if you're able to bypass this tool
then you were able to bypass all those
checks right
but at the same time the case tool might
be a tool that is delivered by a bunch
of your developers in internally or a
third-party software which is deployed
by somebody else
the people who deploy who have the
deployment privileges in the case tool
need not have access to the data
imagine a financial services sort of or
financial records the person who runs
the job may not be an insider to get you
a quarterly report right but they have
the admin privileges to deploy their job
right this is an example in support
that's another example in the sort of a
fr kind of world right so which means
there are two things that must be true
the access must come from the case tool
and the authenticated user or which it
is acting on behalf of right must be a
support engineer right these two things
must be true in order to grant access
thus you have to reason about both of
these identities in order to grant
access such that this privileged insider
cannot create an unauthorized client and
simply access because the only the user
was authorized or was on the policy
similarly the case tool cannot identify
itself and in using its ambient
Authority have broad access to the data
because that's a sure way of getting
inside increasing an insider risk right
so therefore it must be working under
the delegated authority of a customer
support engineer right and this is a
very key reason why we need to create
yet another policy engine for sto and
not simply rely on existing network
policy engines that exist in communities
and outside right this is not a solved
problem now it's a it's a new policy
language that we are building and we
will continue to work on this right over
time but this is the primary use case
that we are targeting right there's
multiple channels through which
different users can access for different
use cases right and how do we make it
easy for you to be able to build such
policies and implement user data
protection within your production
environment so we talked a lot about two
identities and origin identities and you
might wonder what what about HTTP
service interactions like my sequel for
example and the answer is that's true we
cannot reason about the identity on the
at the sequel protocol level because
today on why doesn't understand it
hopefully over time we want to increase
the number of
a layer seven protocols that we
understand but today we're limited to
http G RPC as the primary protocols that
we support right so in such cases yes we
are not able to reason so strongly about
who is the user on behalf of which the
call is coming from but we can still
constrain which are the prom which any
access can be presented from so for
example even if you have the my sequel
credentials you should not be able to
access the database from anywhere except
through service a right and we can
enforce that property right so no matter
what like if your my sequel credentials
were stolen or it was in a source
control system somewhere and somebody
accessed it you dish will still not gain
access because they have to go through
service a and that is still being
enforced so there's still a VIN for TCP
communications outside of where we don't
understand the layer 7 protocol the last
part is platform implements security by
default throughout this talk you might
realize that I've kept talking about how
is to implements all of these I've never
said how your application needs to
change in order to adopt any of this
posture all of this complex
technological paradigms are all
expressed as policies that get enforced
at the proxy level right so these
include encryption of data in transit it
includes the ability to auto-rotate
certs and keys a very hard problem
actually to do this at scale right and
do it properly so to ensure that you
have the right cryptographic hygiene how
do you protect user data access are
using both identities right this has
been traditionally been a hard problem
to enforce consistently across and how
do you monitor security posture
consistently across the heterogeneous
environment right now you have the
ability to do all of that because you
are able to use something like Sto the
last point deserves a little more
attention since I did not cover it
before and it's important to understand
that an in a new world let's say you
have a MapReduce workload that comes up
on a bunch of containers access your
sensitive data as a bad job and then
disappears it was a bad job you go back
look at your network flow logs a week
later a month later and try to explain
to your internal and external auditors
what just happened
a bunch of IP showed up contacted this
back-end IP and then a bunch of IPs
again showed up new IPs that contacted
something else
we have no idea what that IP actually
meant because it's completely different
work that ran in different points in
time right now you can actually have
logs that has an identity for that
workload not of the host right and
you're now able to have this visibility
across a heterogeneous set of
environments heterogeneous set of
protocols including the TCP protocol
which I just explained who acts as the
my sequel database is still expressible
as an identity right so you're able to
do that right so you're able to
understand that and it makes your
network acts of logs much more
meaningful in this new environment and
it helps you go through your security
and compliance or it's much more easily
write and and you're able to do this in
a consistent manner independent of your
infrastructure so with that I would like
to just explain how you can get started
if this is something that is of interest
to you how you can get engaged to start
without strongly recommend that you read
our infrastructure security papers and
in particularly the application
transport security paper so that you
have a deeper understanding of how this
actually works at a deep technical level
and then to engage an Sto you can start
by reading the blogs and going to our
website which has the concepts a bunch
of examples and how to get started in
open source on Google Cloud we have an
sto on gke which is sort of makes it
much more easy for you to just get
started so strongly recommend that as a
way to get started on a hands-on basis
if you want to know more about what we
are doing is Google secret sauce around
sto please reach out to me at some Rodri
at Google calm right and I'm happy to
sort of help work with you to give you
more information about what we are doing
to make this much more magical for you
so thank you all for taking the time and
having the patience to go through a
fairly technically complex topic I hope
this was a good use of your time and
there's a lot of interesting talks about
service mesh that have happened during
next some have already occurred some are
coming up please feel free to attend
those you those which are coming up and
or go and look at the videos for those
which have already occurred if you
haven't attended them already your
feedback is greatly appreciated we don't
have a moderator for the Dory but
if you do ask questions we can on the
dory we can certainly look at it and
come back to you offline in the
meanwhile you have a few minutes like a
4-man so if anybody has a few questions
you can take a couple of questions right
now
[Music]